hi everyone I'm Iceland Greenberg and
I'm here at cook on Santiago 2019 I'm a
senior software engineer at Google and
today I gave a talk on binary
authorization in kubernetes it was a
joint heart with neuron Levin who is one
of the biggest contributors to both
graduates and credit projects and we
discussed how gravis and critters can
help you secure your software supply
chain if you're not familiar with the
term suffer supply chain it's basically
all the stuffs that take you through
committing the code to the code base and
then building it in testing it using
continuous integration pipelines and
then deploying it to kubernetes using
which it is delivery framework and in
this talk we also discussed how to
populate the data into repairs neuron
showed a nice demo
Fitz restored for deleting the data and
then deploying that to cover Linnaeus
and using critters to actually get the
deployment depending on whether you
found critical vulnerabilities or not so
if you came to the stock thank you very
much if you haven't seen it yet I highly
recommend you check it out when it's
online and please come by the Google
both at coop and Santiago thank you
[Music]